andrés gracias por la invitación a
conversar con ustedes
bueno en este momento creo que hay más
certeza más dudas que certezas hay más
inquietudes sobre lo que puede llegar a
ocurrir en los próximos días y semanas
sobre lo que es comparado con lo que
realmente sabemos que puede ocurrir
como bien comentados al inicio pero que
una de las principales inquietudes es
sobre cómo nos quiere llevar la empresa
a hacer nuevamente privada eso va a
traer muchísimos cambios sobre todo con
lo que es la rendición de cuentas y cómo
se toman las decisiones dentro de la
empresa
y obviamente en los últimos días han
salido distintos dichos sobre cómo vamos
que guiar a la empresa en estas nuevas
decisiones y justamente llevar a la
empresa privada paramos implicaría como
el primer paso para poder hacer los
cambios drásticos que él consideran
necesarios a esta altura solamente
tenemos sus dichos realmente y toda la
comunidad que se dedica a analizar sobre
todo la moderación de contenidos sobre
todo las problemáticas de libertad de
expresión en internet está con bastante
inquietud justamente por estos cambios
que puede ser a realizar en detrimento
de cómo se maneja la plataforma respecto
al contenido de sus usuarios a propósito
de lo que usted menciona no se ha
mostrado reacio a la forma en que
twitter modera el contenido y la
principal preocupación de los usuarios
es que en manos del multimillonario esta
red social podría hacer igual que para
leer o querer que son redes
conservadoras donde existe poca
moderación frente a discursos de odio o
desinformación que podemos esperar
sí sí tal cual la preocupación de que de
que twitter se convierta o en retroceso
justamente de todo lo que han avanzado
en últimos años
en un ambiente mucho más propenso al
spam al discurso de odio al acoso
realmente es bastante alto a la
preocupación no
creo que la visión que tenemos sobre la
libertad de expresión es bastante
anticuada para lo que implica una
plataforma una empresa que brinda una
plataforma de generación de contenidos
en internet
y eso en el último texto que hemos en el
que participó quedó bastante en
evidencia sobre sobre esta visión de la
libertad de expresión que él tiene que
si la tratamos de llevar a otras
regiones a otras partes del mundo va a
tener muchísimas dificultades en
implementar los cambios que él quiere no
teniendo en cuenta diversos contextos
culturas idiomas ideologías políticas va
a encontrarse con una gran dificultad
ahí bueno qué significa que una sola
persona concentre tanto poder en una red
social como twitter muy brevemente por
favor
sí creo que volvemos al punto también
sobre la rendición de cuentas no es muy
difícil querer hacer paralelismos con lo
que ocurre hoy en día con con facebook o
con meta justamente con la posición que
tiene mark zuckerber dentro de la
empresa para la toma de decisiones y
justamente creo que el problema
principal que se está evidenciando o
tratando de evidenciar ahora es que al
llevar a twitter al prêt à privado se le
está dando muchísimo poder a una sola
persona sobre un espacio que es tan
importante para para la discusión hoy en
día no